andré castelot avis la mort c'est un
sommeil sans rêve c'est faux la mort
c'est être décédé alors que le sommeil
c'est juste dormir donc n'importe quoi
en fait déboucher comme ça sur le
sommeil qui en a plein et aujourd'hui je
vous propose dans des bunkers 7 ni plus
ni moins
[Musique]
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet
juste un petit truc cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par emma vous souvenez
s'était déjà eu pour ma vidéo sur la
paralysie du sommeil et à l'époque je
vous disais ça désespère pas de pouvoir
tester leur surmatelas bientôt et la
voilà ça y est je les tester et regarder
et même pas que je dors comme un poupon
c'est que je dors comme un foetus dans
le ventre de sa mère car oui parce que
pour ceux qui savent pas emma c'est
ainsi qu'ils vendent et surmatelas donc
mais aussi des matelas des oreillers des
couettes du linge de lit etc peut il
vous propose d'améliorer la qualité de
votre sommeil avec leurs produits et moi
je vous propose d'améliorer la qualité
de votre pouvoir d'achat avec une
réduction je vous expliquera dans une
minute mais déjà comment ça se passe eh
ben ça se passe sans bouger de chez vous
parce que faut reconnaître que les
matelas c'est pas évident a très mal
donc vous choisissez votre matelas vous
oreiller à mémoire de forme votre
couette en microfibre que sais-je vous
passez commande et 72 heures plus tard
vous êtes livrés dans des petits cartons
sympa facile à ouvrir la livraison elle
est gratuite et vous avez s'ennuie décès
sans risque donc si au bout de trois
mois vous n'êtes pas convaincu vous
pouvez renvoyer tout ça gratuitement
tous les matelas sont garantis 10 ans
leur matelas emma original et le plus
vendu en france depuis deux ans et leur
matelas hybride a été élu meilleur choix
ufc que choisir en 2021 du titre d'info
que je vous donne comme ça mais je vous
vois à frétiller oui je vous ai parlé
d'une réduction je vous offre moins 10 %
sur tout le site français et surtout le
site belge avec le code dtc 10% de
réduction en plus des promos et des
réductions qui a déjà sur le site là par
exemple jusqu'au 19 juillet ya jusqu'à
-50% sur tout le site avec le col d'ey
tfc et -10% en plus et le code est
valable 6 mois donc vous avez jusqu'à
fin décembre voilà donc si ça vous
intéresse et que vous avez envie d'en
profiter n'hésitez pas à les y de ma
part vous avez les liens dans la
description tête vous plaisir ceci étant
dit attaquons-nous sans plus attendre à
ces fameux bullshit sur le sommeil en
commençant par le premier une bonne nuit
ces huit heures de sommeil voilà on
commence par le bullshit de base celui
qu'on entend plus déjà d'où ça vient
cette histoire de huit heures de sommeil
va ça vient d'un chiffre qui dit qu'un
adulte d'or entre 7 heures et 9 heures
par nuit en moyenne mais attention il ya
plusieurs problèmes avec ce chiffre déjà
on parle d'adultes parce qu'en fonction
de l'âge qu'on a on n'a pas besoin du
même nombre d'heures de sommeil pour
récupérer les enfants ils ont besoin de
plus par exemple ensuite cette moyenne
et bagdad en cinquante ans on a perdu
une heure trente de sommeil par nuit
donc on est passé sous les 7 heures et
pour finir on n'est pas tous égaux
devant semaine en plus de la gela plein
de facteurs qui font que vous allez
avoir besoin de plus ou moins d'heures
de sommeil pour être en forme des
facteurs comme votre mode de vie
votre état de santé ou juste votre type
de sommeil on en a déjà parlé dans une
vidéo que je vous invite à retourner
voir le sommeil c'est des cycles avec
différentes phases dont le sommeil
profond pendant lequel on récupère et en
réalité c'est entre quatre et six cycles
de 90 à 100 minutes donc vous voyez
c'est pas la même chose pour tout le
monde il y en a qui se réveille reposer
au bout de six heures de sommeil et il y
en a qui ont besoin de neuf ou dix
heures oui il n'y a pas de règles et ça
peut même changer au cours de votre vie
les heures dormies avant minuit compte
double et non non plus là encore c'est
un raccourci qui part d'une réalité il
ya plusieurs choses qui sont importantes
avec le sommeil respecter son rythme de
sommeil déjà c'est à dire aller se
coucher toujours à peu près aux mêmes
heures et ne pas lutter contre la
fatigue quand on la ressent et dormir
dans des bonnes conditions parmi ces
conditions et là encore je vous renvoie
à la vidéo précédente pour rentrer dans
le détail il ya le calme et l'obscurité
le calme bon bah on comprend bien
pourquoi et c'est vrai que si vous vous
couchez et que vous vous levez à peu
près en même temps que tout le monde a
vu que tout le monde dort en même temps
vous et a pas trop de bruit a pas trop
de mouvements et c'est donc logiquement
si vous vous couchez et que vous vous
levez plus tard que tout le monde ok les
gens qui sont d'où ils vont peut-être
perturbé votre sommeil pour l'obscurité
c'est un peu différent l'alternance
veille sommeil elle est régulée par
notre horloge biologique qui dépend
elle-même de ce qu'on appelle le rythme
circadien qui dure 24 heures parmi les
trucs comme une action sur notre sommeil
il ya une substance qui est sécrétée
dans notre cerveau par la glande pinéale
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler
c'est la mélatonine et la production de
mélatonine elle intervient entre le
coucher et le lever du soleil mais notre
organisme comment il le sait si le
soleil est le vous coucher grâce à
l'obscurité donc si votre mode de vie
vous permet pas de calais vos horaires
de sommeil sur les heures
d'ensoleillement vous sur l'emploi du
temps de nos voisins c'est à dire de
vous coucher avant minuit et de vous
lever vers 7 heures il ya quand même
moyen de s'en sortir du moment que vous
arrivez à dormir dans le calme et dans
l'obscurité ça va le faire enfin pas
seulement on va en reparler tout on dort
mieux quand on est bien au chaud voilà
je vous avais dit qu'on allait en parler
tout de suite c'est ça dormir bien au
chaud sous la couette dans son pyjama en
pilou est ce que c'est vraiment le
secret pour passer une bonne nuit si
j'en parle dans une vidéo sur les moules
frites c'est que ces noms là les idées
je sais qu on vous la fait pas à vous
donc non on dort pas mieux quand on a
chaud c'est même le contraire d'ailleurs
je suis sûr que vous allez remarquer que
vous dormez moins bien l'été quand il
fait trop chaud alors jetez pas votre
couette 1 attention par contre changer
la température de votre chambre elle
doit être plus basse que dans le reste
de la maison en fait les recommandations
pour un sommeil optimale c'est de dormir
dans une pièce à 18 degrés là même qui
descendent jusqu'à 16 la raison elle est
simple c'est encore une histoire de
rythme circadien et d'horloge biologique
notre corps il est naturellement plus
froid la nuit que la journée ça va de
pair avec la production de mélatonine
donc si vous vous couchez dans une
chambre frêche la température de votre
corps elles baissent aussi et ça vous
prépare au sommet si on réveille un
somnambule il peut mourir
là pardon mais y'a pas d'autre façon de
le dire le seulement du l'isthme c'est
ce qu'on appelle une part à sony c'est à
dire un comportement anormal ou une
expérience indésirables pendant le
sommeil ou l'endormissement on en avait
déjà parlé dans une vidéo sur les
étranges maladie du sommeil j'ai remis
le lien dans la description de la vidéo
vous connaissez mais alors comment ça se
passe et bah comme souvent dans ce genre
d'histoire ya un décalage là en
l'occurrence votre cerveau d'or si vous
voulez mais votre corps est réveillé non
mais je schématise vous avez l'idée vous
rappeler la paralysie du sommeil votre
corps d'or mais votre cerveau et
réveiller ben là c'est l'inversé dans un
cas comme dans l'autre il ya zéro danger
vous n'allez pas mourir alors si
attention il ya un danger avec le second
but le danger c'est que le somnambule
fasse n'importe quoi et ça ce mal voire
passe par la fenêtre ical donc vous avez
deux options si vous tombez sur
quelqu'un qui se baladent en dormant
soit vous raccompagner cette personne
tranquillement dans sa chambre et vous
la remettez au lit sans la réveiller si
vous y arrivez soit vous l'a réveillé
pour éviter qu'elles se passent mal
parce qu'il n'y a absolument aucun
danger à le faire alors si attention il
ya un danger mais pas pour la personne
qui dort plus tôt pour celles qui la
réveille oui le seul risque c'est que le
ou la somnambule soit un petit peu perdu
en se réveillant et que dans la
confusion elles sentent un peu agressé
donc qu elles se débattent voir qu'elle
colle une ou deux golden au passage
d'ailleurs personnellement je pense que
c'est de là que vient le mot shit c'est
quelqu'un qui avait pas du tout envie de
s'en prendre une part un somnambule et
kddi ah non je ne rêvais pas à la non
surtout pas ah ben il pourrait mourir
savez si on dort pas assez on meurt et
ben non plus non on ne meurt pas quand
on dort pas assez sauf dans des cas très
particuliers mais dans ces cas-là n'y a
pas que le sommeil qui est en cause ou
dans le cas de l'insomnie fatale
familial qui est une maladie qui est
rarissime pour l'immense majorité des
gens est privé de sommeil même pendant
très longtemps ça n'est pas mortel mais
attention c'est quand même pas fou
d'ailleurs je rappelle que c'est une
technique de torture qui était quand
même assez courante à guantanamo bonne
idée mais grâce à un américain qui
s'appelle randy garner a qui restent et
264 heures sans dormir dans les années
60 hong kong un peu mieux pourquoi on
n'en meurt pas oui 264 heures ça fait
quand même 11 jours son orgue pendant sa
période s'endormir l'activité cérébrale
de garde mère elle a été surveillé et
elle a montré quelque chose qui a été
vérifiée depuis en période de privation
de sommeil nos neurones il s'adapte et
certaines zones de notre cerveau se met
en pause pendant que les autres
continuent à fonctionner en gros ils
s'arrangent entre eux pour faire la
sieste à tour de rôle mais attention ça
empêche pas que au fur et à mesure ça
devient quand même de plus en plus
difficile avait il ya des troubles de la
concentration qui finissent par
apparaître des difficultés à structurer
sa pensée et à l'exprimer voir des
hallucinations ou carrément des troubles
psychiatriques comme la paranoïa par
exemple et je vous parle pas de
l'augmentation des risques de maladies
comme les maladies cardiovasculaires
c'est un long terme mais quand même ça
compte voilà donc pas dormir pendant
plusieurs jours d'affilée sais pas vous
mais on finit par s'endormir avant de
mourir donc qu'à mes mots donc là on
était dans les cas extrêmes mais
retenait quand même deux choses non on
meurt pas quand on dort pas assez mais
oui c'est mauvais pour votre santé
physique et mentale donc dorment et
non pas maintenant je n'ai pas fini pour
dormir bien dormir klein oui c'est un
vieux proverbe bof je sais pas si vous
connaissez ça parle d'alcool alors
éventuellement je dis bien
éventuellement à toute petite dose
l'alcool ça peut aider à s'endormir sans
avoir de conséquences sur le reste de la
nuit par contre à grosse dose bon ça
aide à s'endormir d'un peu trop même des
fois mais ça a des effets super négatif
sur la qualité du sommeil surtout en
deuxième partie de nuit déjà ça perturbe
les cycles de sommeil leur durée les
différentes phases ça c'est nécessaire
pour bien récupérer et puis entre les
douleurs à l'estomac les sueurs le mal
de crâne qui commencent à arriver quand
l'alcoolémie diminue autant vous dire
que la fin de nuit elle et pas vous au
final on se réveille plus souvent
pendant la nuit on se réveille plus tôt
le matin donc on dort mal et on n'est
pas reposer au réveil sans parler de la
gueule de bois et de ce qu'on va appeler
pudiquement l'embarras gastrique
l'embarras gastrique non alors -
pudiquement la bonne gerbes des familles
on parle de dé gulli qui dort dîne allez
un petit dernier pour la route le bon
vieux dicton de sagesse populaire comme
on aime dormir ça vaut un bon bifteck
pas du tout non seulement le sommeil ça
remplace pas un repas on voit pas
vraiment comment ce serait possible de
toute façon mais en plus aller se
coucher l'estomac vide c'est une
mauvaise idée alors peut-être que vous
vous dites mais où mais la nuit ont fait
rien donc on n'a pas besoin de prendre
des forces en mangeant avant bas hockey
notre corps la nuit et tourne au ralenti
mais tourne quand même donc il a besoin
de carburant le premier risque c'est
d'être réveillés par la fin soit d'en
avoir conscience soit ne pas en avoir
conscience dans les deux cas soit c'est
désagréable et de toute façon ça nuit à
la qualité du sommeil et puis si vous
faites une hypoglycémie en dormant c'est
à dire si votre taux de sucre dans le
sang baisse trop non seulement ça va
perturber la qualité de notre sommeil
mais en plus vous allez vous réveiller
complètement dans le pâté voir avec un
bon mal de crâne donc le conseil c'est
le soir manger des trucs pas trop lourd
à digérer parce que ça non plus ça aide
pas à bien dormir mais manger genre des
féculents et des légumes on est loin
d'avoir fait le tour de tous les boules
shit sur le sujet mais de toute façon je
vais refaire des vidéos sur le sommeil
je sais que ça vous intéresse en
attendant voilà c'était déjà une
première fournée on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]